en savoir un petit peu plus parce que
patrick vous êtes comme moi vous avez vu
c'est magnifique ce qu'est la magnifique
et c'est d'autant plus magnifique de
corinne qui est ici à une aventure
extraordinaire
elle a repris une manufacture mais au
départ franchement corinne c'était pas
du tout votre truc va continuer parce
que ça vaut le détour ça pourrait
presque faire un film ça patrick en fait
au départ j'ai travaillé pendant 20 ans
dans la pub à publicis et puis au bout
de 20 ans j'en ai eu ras-le-bol
ça pollue le et je me suis dit qu'est ce
que je vais faire maintenant
j'avais plusieurs possibilités
j'avais vraiment envie treille dans la
création je ne savais pas du tout que
j'allais reprendre une entreprise encore
moins une manufacture
j'ai repris des études pendant deux ans
j'ai fait à n'diaye à paris à l'institut
français de la mode et mon mémoire de
fin d'études en fait j'ai écrit un livre
parce que je suis un peu jusqu'au
boutiste je pense que je suis un peu
comme vous quand j'ai envie de faire
quelque chose je vais jusqu'au bout de
mes envies mes passions et donc j'ai
écrit ce livre sur les manufactures
françaises de l'art de vivre entre mythe
et réalité je me suis dit ben voilà
c'est ce que je vais faire demain
et aujourd'hui ce genre et viva las et
donc j'ai repris ma manifeste de digoin
en 2014
on a relancé l'activité en septembre
elle était à l'arrêt quelques mois est
en fait cette belle endormie j'ai
franchi les portes et là je me suis dit
ça sera ici et nulle part ailleurs et je
me suis battu pendant deux ans pour
reprendre cette entreprise c'est
important de dire que vous vous êtes
battus parce que là pour reprendre un
scénario vous connaissez le scénario de
coline serreau qui vous allez chez les
résidents dans la crise au départ
c'était là la taupe galère parce que là
vous résumer super vite
c'est arrivé en saône-et-loire pourquoi
pourquoi la saône et loire
parce qu'en fait c'est louis 26 ans
alors j'habite en syrie mais c'est un
peu compliqué j'habite annecy est en
fait c'est une amie qui originaire de
saône-et-loire qui m'a dit écoute vallat
appel ce monsieur il ya à digoin il a
une entreprise qui souhaite céder donc
je les appelais j'ai pris rendez vous je
suis arrivé à la manufacture qui date de
1875 sur le site d'origine
et là coup de coeur et je me suis dit
c'est bon c'est ici et je me suis battue
alors certes ça n'a pas été un long
fleuve tranquille de son de vous dire
que reprendre une entreprise en france
c'est juste très très compliqué vous
arrivez vous êtes de la pub donc vous
êtes catalogué c'est la parisienne
la marque est heureuse et c'est bon et
les banques voilà ne veulent pas vous
suivre
alors j'ai eu beaucoup de chance dans ma
va dire dans la quête est dans ma
démarche c'est que j'ai rencontrés dans
mon réseau en fait d actionner enfin les
investisseurs et aujourd'hui on est 12
et ce sont vraiment des gens qui
comprennent ce que je veux faire de la
manufacture parce qu'un fonds
d'investissement ne peut pas comprendre
ce genre de choses y ait une part de
folie
en fait je suis juste un peu tout le
monde à lire était juste un peu perché
quoi ouais enfin quand on voit cette
région en tout cas on se dit que c'est
plutôt sympa un peu trahi sais pas ce
que vous en pensez mais aujourd'hui vous
travaillé pour les plus grands
oui c'est vrai voilà il faut le dire et
on va donner des noms
on va dire ducasse on va dire des
grandes chaînes hôtelières etc
et puis dans des concepts stores com
merci on travaille beaucoup aux états
unis dans des très belles boutiques
aussi à londres en australie voilà alors
toujours produit faites vous là
aujourd'hui
alors en fait cette entreprise qui a été
créée en 1875 ce que j'ai vraiment mon
coup de coeur ça a été au delà de
l'entreprise ça a été sur son savoir
faire sur un territoire fortement lié à
la céramique sur le grès parce que c'est
une pâte degrés on fabrique c'est le bac
bleu gré à partir de d'argile qui
viennent de bourgogne et ça je vraiment
j'y tiens absolument
et puis c'est vraiment un projet voilà
pour faire rayonner tous ses produits
traditionnels qui au départ ont été
créés pour les métiers de bouche pour
les charcutiers pour les fromagers pour
les moutardier pour les fabricants de
dycker et donc c'était des produits
vraiment destiné aux professionnels et
pas au grand public et je me suis dit
mais c'est vraiment dommage que si ces
beaux produits dans lequel il ya des
terrines des pâtes et des rillettes de
la moutarde on puisse pas les utiliser
au quotidien et surtout c'est vraiment
une démarche de transmission c'est à
dire que moi ce qui me révolte
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est vraiment
dans des produits qu'on achète des
produits à bas coûts on achète qu'on
jette qui ne durent rien moi j'ai une
grand mère inquiète épicière
et qui avait dit vendait des produits
digoin des plats à gratin dans lequel on
est là dedans
enfin j'ai des souvenirs mais
extrêmement ému et puis on sent la
passion un kokorine en parle 1 à
vraiment les yeux s'illuminent séduit
mène aussi c'est ça c'est ça j'ai
embauché dix personnes aujourd'hui on
est 17 alors on est sur un site de 2
hectares avec donc un site industriel au
bord du canal
est ce que je veux c'est vraiment faire
rayonner cette manufacture s'est produit
travailler ça ce sont tous des formes
anciennes parce qu'on a un gros
patrimoine
et puis c'est surtout partager cette
passion avec des gens on a ouvert le
site au tourisme industriel donc on a
plein de gens qui viennent visiter et il
y aura des portes ouvertes d'ailleurs au
mois de mai si je me trompe pas les 25
26 et 27 mai aussi vous en avez un peu
plus loin mais oui mais là les
prochaines c'est au maniement des crocs
à l'avant ok la manufacture de digoin
avant le direct aussi c'est possible
c'est paf à l'autre bout de la planète
comme vous le disait fort justement en a
pour tous les prix pour toutes les
bourses
oui c'est un très vieux produit produit
c'est une assiette égouttoir
pour laver les fruits rouges en fait on
n'est pas sous l'eau ça va très bien
contre cassis a par exemple la groseille
parfait bon ses framboises